he's the Commissioner of the big 12 the
fourth full-time commissioner of the big
12 since 2012 Bob Bulls be back on the
program Commissioner thanks for joining
us how are you I'm great dan good
morning to you clear this up of the
taunting penalty when did this rule put
into place white why now with Oklahoma
and Texas well it's kind of a tempest in
a teapot but the the genesis of it was
that we had a conference call with the
two head coaches and our supervisor of
officials on Monday and it was mostly to
take care of the logistics for the game
this weekend and head steward who was
who runs our football operation was also
on the phone call and and Lincoln Riley
asked about the situation with horns
down and and our supervisor accurately
said that it had been called in the
Texas West Virginia game and the the
rulebook is fairly specific the NCAA
rule book rule 9.2 talks about on sports
like conduct and you know when anything
rises to the level of taunting that's
probably going to get called I don't
think that we're going to be flagging
the fans nor are we going to be
overreacting we have a very veteran
recruiting of referee and a very veteran
officiating crew and I really don't
think this is going to end up being a
problem but the fact is that any time a
student-athlete on the field is doing
something that incites the crowd or is
intended to demean another player or is
unnecessarily drawing attention to
himself the rulebook calls for the
penalty be called and so you know it's
sort of taken on a life of its own and
and I think we've made the officiating
crews job a little more difficult
perhaps but I don't expect that it's
going to be a challenge but we we admit
to wanting a a sports like conduct
environment that is
appropriate and that's difficult to do
sometimes with these rivalry games but
that was the attempt by our supervisor
was just to make sure that we were going
to have a game environment that was fair
to both teams and that was consistent
with our sportsmanship expectations okay
why isn't horns up they taunt well it
could be it could be a taunt good
virtually anything could be a taunt
flipping off the crowd could be oh I get
that commissioner but I'm saying horns
up if if a Texas player does horns up to
celebrate as he's crossing the endzone
that's a taunt if it feels like would he
be flagged if you had that with the
Texas player well it depends on the
situation you know if if a tackler made
a tackle and stood over the top of the
person he tackled and and and taunted
him either with that kind of a sign or
by pounding his chest or pointing at him
or firing imaginary guns those kinds of
things could all be considered taunting
and so you know the the mere act by
itself
does not constitute on sports like
behavior but it certainly could this has
taken on a life of its own as you said
it's almost like it's made even worse by
or is the media making it worse your
Commissioner well I you know I think
that because it came up early in the
week and because this is a one of the
best rivalries in all of college
football there's there's always lots of
lots of enthusiasm on all sides of the
issue and and so you know it I don't
think it was ever intended to get out as
a public matter but our supervisor had a
question from a coach and he tried to
answer it is honestly as he could and
and so it has taken on a life of its own
but I expect that will end up with a
great game tomorrow and I I don't expect
that we're
going to have a lot of on sports like
behavior that's just not the nature of
these two coaches and these are two
excellent football teams with a lot to
play for and I expect that we'll have a
great game okay can you see a scenario
where horns down is not flagged yeah I
think if it's if it's not intended to do
the things that I I said earlier you do
demean an opponent to it taunt an
opponent to draw attention to oneself
you know the rule is fairly clear it's a
page and a half that details what on
sports like conjunct is and and so if if
any action rises to the level of
unsportsmanlike eye it it will be called
on the other hand there can be lots of
things done to celebrate that are not on
sports like and they shouldn't be called
we're talking to Bob Bowles be the big
12 Commissioner are you uh you know firm
on a final four how would you feel about
a team playoff well I don't you know I
would never say never I think there's a
lot right about the the fourteen playoff
and and what we wanted to have happened
an and when I say we I mean the ten
commissioners of the FBS conferences we
wanted to make sure we kept the bowl
system strong and and I think we've done
that by embedding these games in the in
the bowl system we wanted to keep
October in November as good as it's
always been because I really think it's
the best regular-season in all of sports
every week is an elimination game and
then we wanted to encourage
intersectional contests in September
which we always had trouble
accommodating and and now I think it's
it's better than it's ever been before
in terms of some of the intricate under
conference and and intersectional
matchups so I think in large measure
we've we've met our objectives there's
there's always going to be a musical
chairs component to have
ten conferences chasing for spots and
that's particularly true for the the
five autonomy conferences but you know I
think that's one of the reasons why it's
so interesting I think we have to be a
little bit careful too because this this
playoff enjoys about 85% support from
the public and it's far better than the
Alliance or the coalition or the BCS as
predecessors and so we've made a lot of
progress and we and we're just five
years into a 12 year agreement on our TV
but that's not to say that it couldn't
evolve and that's not to say that it
won't evolve I just think there's a lot
write about it and I think it's the
compromises that were made in order to
get us to this position have not changed
and so I think we I think we need to be
cautious
but I would certainly never say never
yeah I think that if we could still we
could I think even emphasize the bowl
games more because you would have games
coming up that would actually have
meaning there'd be more teams involved
storylines in there this weekend would
be huge because these would be
elimination games now you can say their
elimination games but northwestern is
not moving on if they beat Ohio State
Pitts not moving on if they'd be Clemson
so this is a big game you know if Texas
wins they're not moving on so that's
where I love if you had eight teams and
you were able to create more storylines
here then you make that regular season
even more dynamic so I'm all in on eight
it took me a long time to convince
people to go to four because everybody
was sold on the BCS but if you had the
BCS now Bob you would have Notre Dame
undefeated on the outside just like we
did
Auburn back in 2004 so maybe we get to
eight I think eventually we'll get to
eight because everybody will make their
money we keep the Bulls and you keep the
integrity of the regular season so
that's my hope
well you know there's a there's also the
middle ground of going to six at some
point in time but one of the things that
that is a challenge if you want to keep
it in
the major bowl games is if you don't
play this weekend and there isn't any
certainty that that would be the case
now the one thing that's nice about
playing if you did it this weekend was
the losers could still go on and
participate in the bowl system and the
winners move on to the end of the
semifinals now but if you do it with
another model that would have the games
a little later so the teams had longer
to prepare then all of a sudden you have
a round of games that are the week
before Christmas and if you want to keep
those in the major bowl games then all
of a sudden you're going to have years
where the Rose Bowl in the Sugar Bowl or
somebody else are going to get they're
going to have to move their game before
Christmas and you're talking about a
hundred years of tradition now you could
you could not do them in the bowl games
you could play them on campus sites
there there are a number of different
models that would work you know I having
spent a lot of time in the Upper Midwest
I'm not sure that that plan in Madison
Wisconsin on the 15th of December is
really a great idea for college kids but
Green Bay does it so maybe maybe it's
okay there there are a number of
different components to it
but I don't disagree with what you say I
think that more might indeed be better
we haven't had those conversations in
any sort of serious way and and I don't
expect that we will right away but I as
I say it's it's not inconceivable that
at some point in time we have a serious
conversation about that all right you
have fun this weekend Bob we appreciate
your time good to be on with you Dan as
always and Happy Holidays thank you you
too Bob Bulls B Big twelve Commissioner
there for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]